[Música]
[Aplausos]
muito bonita todos antes de começar a
criar congratular a organização tarefas
é facto extraordinário conseguirem
trazer uma iniciativa tão bem vindo à
nossa cidade que merecemos
e também dizer que estão dizendo que
deixou minha por fim os banhos em dizer
que há exceções que confirmam a regra
não garanto isso mas farei o melhor para
contar a nossa aventura
assim sendo isso temos tudo em comum
depois as treinadoras formei com essa
pequena e modesta na xepa essencial mas
é também neste lado pequeno escrito por
um desafio
imaginem que tenham alterado imagina que
eram pequenos erros disse que não dizer
assim no futuro um todo vai crescer e
vai qual me lá torga que eu sou negro
vai atravessar o douro e ser médico
trabalhar muito aqui e vai realizar
muitas servir os doentes que no futuro
vai ser 2 para essas meninas e ainda
mais - sucesso isso mas por outro lado
do mundo e não vai ser uma destas mesmas
festas vai andar todos os dias para
chegar a esse tempo para fazer isto mais
mas tenho que me preocupar toda uma
missão e que para subir as encostas do
himalaia está normal da ilha foi
completamente devastada pelo sismo e
ainda é freira cicatriz disso a fazer
isto e não sei quanto a vocês que não
iria acreditar mas agora que aconteceu
aconteceu e tudo tem um começo nosso
caso fizemos
participamos fizemos o nosso dever
cívico e tanto em mim como a joana é
como ruim
nós tínhamos sempre um sonho que estava
crescendo de tal modo que o motor o que
parece inevitável não queremos
comercializar ian sempre criança era
desde que tivemos em família a
concretizá lo ela está no e mail dava
pra todo mundo tanto algo diferente em
dispensas ou crias tristezas que virar
voltas
nada que foi difícil não mas também foi
com os acasos
nós temos que usar a desculpa de
componentes com sua história que
no máximo da sua benevolência estavam na
altura do segundo pau e se não ficar
ficar para ajudar crianças e obrigado
portugal e juntamente com a ajuda desta
grande senhora dá sangue da mulher muito
poderosa e um coração muito nevo criar
um campus pressa o campo esperança é o
jô durante muito tempo na loja mais de
300 pessoas ficaram completamente sem
casa e dá um teto comida educação às
crianças atividades e muitas ombreiras
então era pra lá quilos e facto a
paisagem não podia ser mais de pessoas
diferentes animais que não são
diferentes mas têm um caso não deveriam
estou a falar do animal mas que a
estratégia do mar tem um cliente sinta
que estamos habituados a ver línguas ou
letras sabores cheiros outdoors
completamente diferentes e meio
transporte do que dureza também criativo
e acreditem funciona e depois aquelas
diferenças que nós não sabemos que
existem aqui nos esquecemos e queremos
estar muito grande nós vivemos temos
pressa temos pressa nós quando fomos já
tenha passado um ano e meio depois do
sismo e vocês vão ver o menino caiu em
grandes áreas
ele tenha menos habitantes cerca de 200
as crianças estavam com as suas lavras
necessitavam na escola tinham gordinhas
chávez pretende ajudar e guarda já teve
mais acreditadas também para ajudar
e esse é o nosso consultor durante três
meses nós não somos ingênuos serviço e
olhamos vivemos mas consegue perceber
que estava muito sujo muito organizada
faltar material ou imaterial chefe que é
necessário nós fazemos também aquilo que
melhor sabe fazer que as meninas e
meninos do trabalho e com a ajuda das
crianças a transtornou e que o frio
mordeu e uma brincadeira interessantes e
acima de tudo podemos começar a fazer
aquilo que nós vamos fazer é ser médico
a nossa actividade dos erros
principalmente dos tipos da assistência
am atuar em nível agudo nas caixas e na
doença das pessoas que estavam
ou então fizemos também um levantamento
em que vivemos cada um dos habitantes do
campo e procuramos saber se tem algum
problema de seu uso como estava
assustado doença não só para termos um e
tivemos tudo no distrito para o que nós
criamos para que ficasse registado para
capacitar as pessoas que vierem depois
de nós que saber o trabalho que está
sendo feito e também até pelo tipo de
iniciativas mais da média proporcional
pura sem cheiro
e assim foi ajudamos uma 59 anos e acho
que ajudamos muita gente e também fomos
aos estados e às vezes vi uns que não
queriam mais arrojadas do ponto de vista
clínico e executados ea verdade é que
nós temos escondemos pouco tempo era uma
alegria como a vontade de abraçar
aquelas pessoas e à medida que as
ligações em que sendo as todas as
fazendas suas táticas fortes que não se
exprimem respondendo da melhor maneira
com brincadeiras com emoções com aquela
curiosidade típica das crianças e quando
damos conta estamos rodeados de
profissionais de saúde cada vez mais
capacitados ajudar e claro para que as
casas mais exigentes mais diferenciados
ah e também temos que atuar então com as
cardiologia cirurgia da famurs dia nós
vamos recolhendo e atrás da mota ou
então por uma transporte pago pela
cessão
vamos até o hospital para ser orientados
e nesse caso sucesso nós tínhamos o
contributo da melhor maneira
risos da família e foi isso que tantas
pessoas primeiro
só quem sabe nem se lançado também
tivemos nosso pessoal comprando as
bancadas
fomos também professor fomos com pinças
de brincadeiras e claro também que os
árbitros não conseguiu ter uma amante no
players em partilhar com essas crianças
e no final estávamos todos o mesmo
sentimento que era só mais um carinho
quando vamos para o pau não sabíamos que
a nossa maior missão estaria por vídeo
de improviso por circunstância ansiedade
em - na semana tivemos que organizar
dois jovens mulheres com cinco anos de
experiência que vamos organizar toda uma
missão em que seríamos que só como vans
e nível de educação
de água energias lanternas era que o que
vamos ter de estar numa região com motas
e malaias encostado
mesmo na zona montanhosa e cinco horas
no hospital mais próximo onde mil
pessoas nunca tinham visto um médico com
esse desafio
mais uma vez fizemos em 2010 as malhas e
se foi
três horas a caminhar subir em encostas
hindus para ver o mal vai ainda isolada
ou seja 1% em arco para as pessoas que
se encaixam em modo muito do lugar como
eu trabalho pra como tempo em viagens
era possível consultar a esquerda dormir
direito
faça fácil e nunca estarei no
consultório com uma paisagem tão
extraordinária como esta
pessoas como apoiantes jovens no palco
do armazém tributário essencial para
esse contacto clínico e esta é a nossa
saúde espera em filas e filas de pessoas
que vinham durante duas e três horas
pelas montanhas com os miúdos nas costas
com o que ensina a roupa no frio das
montanhas regressar à noite porque houve
erro médico que nunca tinham visto antes
e que estavam a precisar de quatro das
crianças eram a nossa polícia e nós
também temos um monstro está nossa fé no
olímpico
temos que capacitar os artistas não é
com a parte que abrange a parte geral e
temos também o nosso carinho nosso não
circulante nós falando que ela santo não
consigo resistir
o ponto que tem 15 entre os curiosos
sempre a tentar entrar na tenda
tratamento e este era o meu momento se
no final do dia depois de trabalhar solo
sol sem parar e decoração cheia barriga
vazia mas sensação de dever cumprido
apreciar o computing não fazer da melhor
maneira e com o máximo carinho e nós
sabemos até o momento é que os meninos
meio da manhã para nós continuar na
energia que empregava só podendo voltar
isto nunca tinha braga pequeno angeli e
seria que está durante três meses vivia
como os turistas é ver rotinas por
pistas
é fazer ligações intensas nas montanhas
no campo em que seria dado de
brincadeiras com ligações muito intensas
e pela primeira vez passamos o natal
fora de casa e nunca imaginamos que está
com estes doentes estão um fosso tem
preço e claro paisagens de cortar a
respiração
depois com o privilégio que não só
contactando escolado mais pobre mas
esbarravam aceitado a ajuda mas também
por causa da dor ricas fundação
completados com maior luxo que existe
são paulo e tudo isto a mesma
experiência um privilégio extraordinário
e pessoas que aparentemente mais
trafegar antes mas com coração de ouro
com mais de 20 anos de história a ajudar
um para sempre nada em troca
e claro as crianças mesmo elas ou
principalmente elas também nos ajudaram
ativamente e nunca mais esquecer este
grande ajudar e fazer cumprir médico não
é só atuar no local e também a
oportunidade de trabalhar antes de
trabalhar pois completamos a sessão para
tentar perceber o que era necessário
para salvar portugal e como ajuda
solidária das nossas nossos contatos
nossos amigos
incluímos de material escolar metal de
general os doces gostavam dos lados da
canon e como podemos vários braços fomos
entregando as crianças que enchem de
saúde ensinamos também as saudáveis de
comportamento que eu falei que nós
fizemos descobrimos que usava
elementares de fruta eram inexistentes
por isso simplesmente não existiam então
com a nossa metodologia científica e
médica tentamos ensinar essas crianças
entre brincadeira mas quando também
alguma seria nada construtiva estão o
layout dos rios que nós fizemos e
deixamos lá e não foi bem
determinem nós fizemos uma análise
estatística da informação que recolhemos
que visita os anos e que o direito a um
artigo que vai ser publicado no próximo
evento na lista de cardiologia mais
importante no palco e claro uma porta
que ficou aberta porto
e ele possa voltar do mundo mas não é
assim tão diferente comigo
é verdade que nós sem sabermos
tornando-se posteriormente ter aceite
este desafio é medida lei também nossa
colega 800 ac tem estado nos meses antes
durante ou menos no pau e viver também é
ela a sua experiência
apesar da exclusão são assim tão
diferentes selecções e malaias um prato
na mesa pra quem quer que seja dar o que
tem
nós comemos e tal e qual como nash as
nossas avós as nossas avós dodô entre
orban outras montanhas ou como era antes
do palco com suas vivências o vi havia
tal e qual convênios passou as festas
para suas operações
sabe deus nas suas casas ajudaram os
seus dados
tal como nós português também se enganou
claramente as suas crianças também são
curiosas era brincar são tal e qual como
nós também têm o direito à educação como
as nossas também ajudam a superarem as
provas e também tem os seus colegas de
escritório não querem mais exótica e no
final nós vamos aceitar a diferença não
voltar agora com idealismo juíza que
tudo é possível e é só um homem sonhar
em a vida dela não é nada casta é
difícil mas também é extraordinária e eu
venci e o bom é que participem de nós e
do modo como obras anos e que é melhor
para exprimir isso do que um dos maiores
pensadores que algumas vezes jonas nesta
terra e tem a sua arte da expressão
melhor do que ninguém para conseguir
falar da nossa vivência humana e das
nossas emissões
[Aplausos]